SETH VARGO: In this episode
of the Secret Manager video
series, we'll talk about
global secret names
and regional
replication policies.
Should you choose
user-managed or automatic?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In Secret Manager, secret names
are project global resources.
This is because secrets rarely
differ across cloud regions.
As a concrete example, your
Twilio or Twitter API key
doesn't change when you move
your application from US-EAST1
to EUROPE-WEST4.
This is different from other
Google Cloud resources, which
have a tighter coupling to a
particular region or geography.
For example, in
Google Compute Engine.
Virtual machine instances
are bound and referenced
by the zone in which
they're created.
Even though the secret's name
is a project global resource,
the secret's payload is
still stored regionally.
This means that a
secret is globally
addressable by a
single name, but
the underlying secret
material is still
stored in particular regions.
Payload storage may be
an important concern
for regulated customers
or for customers
that have strict
requirements over where
their data is stored--
like banking, fintech,
or health care.
Other customers may prefer
to have their data stored
closer to where they plan to
access it, to minimize latency.
But how do you choose
the regions in which
the secret payloads are stored?
Google Secret Manager
features replication policies,
which give you the freedom
to choose how and where
your secret payload is stored.
To tell us a little bit more
about replication policies,
I think we need to
bring in an expert.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey, Colin.
Thanks for joining us today.
COLIN MAN: Hey, Seth.
Thanks for having me.
SETH VARGO: So Colin is a
software engineer working
on Google Secret Manager.
OK, Colin.
Earlier, I was
telling our viewers
about data storage and
regionalization of Secrets.
Could you tell us
a little bit more
about Secret Manager's
replication policies?
COLIN MAN: Sure, Seth.
Replication policies
offer control
over where your secret
payloads are stored.
Some enterprises
want full control
over the regions in which
their secrets are stored,
while others don't
have a preference.
Secret Manager addresses both
of these customer requirements
and preferences with the
replication policies.
If you don't care about
where your payload is stored,
you should choose an
automatic replication policy.
With automatic
replication, Google Cloud
chooses the best regions to
replicate your secret payload.
This strategy also offers the
highest availability guarantees
for accessing and
creating secrets.
SETH VARGO: OK, Colin,
but which regions
does Secret Manager pick if I
choose automatic replication?
COLIN MAN: That's explicitly
unspecified behavior, Seth.
You should interpret
automatic as I don't care.
SETH VARGO: But
what if I do care?
What if I care too
much about where
my secret payload is stored?
COLIN MAN: Then, you should
choose user-managed replication
policies.
With user-managed replication,
you choose one or more regions
to which to replicate
your secret payloads.
SETH VARGO: Yeah,
but then I'm going
to have to run some Cloud
Function that replicates
my secret payload
and I have to deal
with all the monitoring and
the alerting and the paging
and the 3:00 AM--
COLIN MAN: No, actually--
SETH VARGO: --and
it's just like--
COLIN MAN: Actually, you won't.
User-managed is more
like user selected.
You pick the regions and
Secret Manager automatically
handles the replication.
SETH VARGO: Oh,
that's super cool.
I'm just going to replicate
my secret payload into all the
available Google Cloud regions.
That's going to give me the
most availability and the lowest
latency.
Thanks, Colin.
COLIN MAN: Well, I'd
be careful with that.
SETH VARGO: What?
Why is that?
COLIN MAN: While replicating a
secret payload to every region
improves the reliability
of accessing a secret,
it may decrease the reliability
of adding a secret version.
SETH VARGO: Ah.
OK, that makes sense.
Well, it-- wait.
No, that-- that
doesn't make sense.
Why is that?
COLIN MAN: Well, in order
to add a secret version,
all of the regions you
select must be operational.
If you choose a lot of
regions and any single one
of those regions is
down, you can no longer
add a new secret version.
SETH VARGO: I see.
So depending on
my application, I
can choose to balance
my read availability
and my write
availability accordingly.
COLIN MAN: Exactly.
SETH VARGO: So how many
regions should I choose, Colin?
COLIN MAN: Well,
as you mentioned,
it's heavily dependent
on the application.
As a general recommendation,
you should choose at least two
but no more than five regions.
SETH VARGO: Awesome.
Thanks, Colin.
COLIN MAN: No problem, Seth.
SETH VARGO: OK.
Let's look at how we set a
secret's replication policy
from the Google Cloud console.
First, we choose the secret's
name, initial payload,
and then, we have the option
of selecting regionalization.
Notice that the default behavior
is automatic, since that's
what most customers will choose.
If I want to select specific
regions, I can check the box
and pick the replicated
regions from the menu.
I can also set
replication policies from
the command-line--
using the gcloud tool--
or from the API--
using any of the Secret Manager
SDKs for .NET, Go, Java, PHP,
Node, Python, and Ruby.
Google Secret Manager's
flexible replication policies
give you choice over where
your secrets are stored.
If you don't have specific
regionalization requirements,
choose the automatic
replication policy.
But if you do have specific
regionalization requirements,
pick the user-managed
replication policy
with specific regions.
For even more tips and tricks
with Google Secret Manager,
subscribe to Google
Cloud platform.
[MUSIC PLAYING]